Okay, so basically ma'am, apka jo abhi login url hai, right, jo usse log in karte hai,
uspe HRM ki apas complete permissions hai, apne check kar liye hogi.
Tke, to abhi tak aapne kya kya, masters wajhara create kiye the, assign kiye the, then uske
bhaad apne kuch contracts bhi laga liye hogi employees.
Anji.
Ji, tke.
Ab jo aapne ma'am contracts laga liye usme kuch funding jo the ho gayi the complete matlab
laga liye the apne.
Anji ma'am.
Tke ma'am.
To ma'am, ho cover karna hai part to bara se, ya ho clear aap uske aage kare.
Ma'am, sara starting se bata do merko, mere mind me re to raha ho raha ho raha ho raha
Okay, okay ma'am, okay.
Ma'am, agar aapko contract kisi bhi employee ko hme lagaana hota hai, to aap basi ye assign
salary template ka option rahega, basically.
Anji.
Tke, assign means, jais aji se aapko create karna hoga.
Tke, jo bhi employee ke liye, assign salary template mein, jabbi hum assign karte hai
Ab ho, aapko contract ko, apne is terse ek option open hoga.
Ye.
Right.
Yaha se apke paas employees aage ho jimko aapko assign karna hai.
Basically, jitna bhi aappas total number of employees ho gye, wo sare aapki aapne aate
hai.
Anji.
Tke, apko aap search kar sakto ho, either the employee ID or the name.
Right.
Jis bhi employee ko aapko lagaana hoga, apne search kiya.
For example, mujhe is employee ko lagaana hai, ma search karoogi name se, ho aage hain.
Then yaha select box se aapko select karna hai.
Right, select karne ke baad aappas bottom ek button aayega, assign template ka.
Means, aap isko contract laga rahe ho aapki ke liye mein.
Tke, assign karoogi, assign karne ke liye aappas option hai, copy from salary template, import
from salary.
Dua option kya rahe the hai, ek to aapne contract template create kare rahe hai.
Jo aapne salary template create kiya ho, chaar tarah ke standard created hai.
With PF, without PF, without DSIPF.
Right.
Yaha phir aappas dosa option kya ho uskta hai, ki jo aapne previously employee ko lagaaya
hain.
Ye humne already employee ko lagaaya hain tha.
First date aari hain, humne 31 December tak laga diya tha.
Tke, aage ke liye aap isko hi continue karna chaate ho, December ke baad.
Tke, to aap isko hi as it is copy karoogi, isme jo bhi aapko amount me changes, ya koi
head me changes.
Right, jo bhi karne hoge, wo aap kar sakte ho.
In case, for example, aapko further ke liye hi koi reduction head aage contract ke liye
assign karna hai, to aap yaha se head bhi add kar sakte ho.
Tke, aap contract me change kar sakte ho, upcoming ke liye, 31 December ke baad ki contracts
me.
Tke.
Calculate karte hai hum, to humare pas amount aajata hai, jo bhi contract ke according amount
create ho raha hoga.
Then aap next karoge, to aap se date maangega, ki kap tak ke liye aapko usse assign karna
hai.
Tke, pehle wala jo contract hai, wo aapko already 31 December tak assigned hai.
Tke, to aap jo aap aage assign kar sakte ho, December ke baad kar hi assign kar sakte ho.
Right, ek January se lagega, start date aap dekh rahe ho ki aap freeze aariye January
2026.
Agar mujhe November ka banana hai.
Ha, aapko, man dekho kar November ka banana hai, to phir jo previous contract hai wo aapko
remove karne padege.
Kyuki aapne I think December se banane ke liye bho raha tha na.
Ha na, to wo phir previous contract.
Ja saar mein trial kari ho, to wo to mein November se karungi na.
Agar aap chahe ho November se bhi create kar sakte ho, phir usme agar aapko head mein
koi changes hai na, wo create karne ke baad bhi ho jate hai.
Ye toh mein se contract create karne ka bata hote hai, agar aapko contract ki change karna
hai.
Tke, aap aap jesse batari ho na, aapko November ki for example salary banane hai, wo aap banane
sakte ho.
Uske liye aapko pati salary summary month wise ka use karke, aap pehle dates set kar lo
ki employee ki, kisi ek ki banane lete hai, jesse aapki hi kar lete hai.
Tke, ye salary summary month aapne dekha hoga, humne December ki create ki thi.
Tke, for example ye aapki November ki hoti, isi toh aap November ki bhi banane liye jega.
Wahi aapas jo ye hai, mark attendance month wise, November ki poore month ki karke hai.
Asana aap mujhe hi bata ho, jesse maine na driver ki banane lete hai.
Hmm.
Tke, to wo maine shahe contract nahi lagaye tha usme.
Okay.
Hmm.
Ye hai employee?
Ye.
Tke.
Aapne isse view kiya, aapko ye doubt hai, isko contract lagaya hai na, yaha pe na salary
template rehta hai ye.
Okay.
Agar contract laga ho, toh yaha wo show karega, yaha wo show nahi kara, means yaha pe contract
nahi laga ho.
Nahi laga ho.
Hmm.
Wahi aapko contract lagana hai iska, yaha se sign salary template se.
Laga do main?
Anji.
Okay.
Aapko click, yaha pe click karna hai, select karoge assign template, then dekho yaha pe
koi nahi aara hai, it means isko previous koi laga hi nahi hua.
Tke, toh aapko yaha se assign karna hai isse.
Okay.
Kya hai, aapko iska, wahi 10,000 wala system?
Nahi, with hai, with, with.
With laga hai?
Anji.
P, F, E, S, I both?
Aur Labour Welfare Fund bhi lagayega.
Toh a basic itna rakhna hai aapko amount matata jaye.
Basic rakhna hai, aapne 14,390.
14,390.
Is tarah se aap basic amount enter karna.
Incase koi D.A. hai, grade pe toh wo enter jasut pe nahi hai, toh aap iske skip kar dena,
zero heat.
Okay.
Chiken.
Ab deduction mein, waise toh ho E, S, P, F, I wo automatically calculate terega, jo
aapne click diya tha.
Aapne ye dekho, ye automatic mein aara hai aapka ye 158.
Jee, 158 na up to amount hai.
Anji.
Jo salary, even up to amount hota hai, dekho jo salary.
Abhi humare paas E, S, I iska 101 hai.
Okay.
Hmm.
Toh utna hi rahega.
Dekho ma'am kya hota hai, ye iska amount hai.
Chiken.
14,390 ka 0.75%.
Anji.
Wo iska aayega.
E, S, I basically.
Ye up to amount hai.
Up to amount ho bata bote maximum kaha tak jasut te.
Abhi meri jo salary sheet mein iska amount hai 101.
Okay.
E, S, I.
Abhi me isko change kar sakte ho na.
Ma'am up to amount kyu change karna hai.
I think 101 hi banega.
Ek min main calculate bhi kar lete ho saath saath hai.
Aapkar hum dekhe humara hai 14,390.
14,390 ka aap kya rahe ho 0.75%.
Ye baithega aapka 107 kuch baithega.
Aapka kitna hai?
Ye mere paas 101 hai, ye iska amount iska.
Haan, toh itna hi baithega.
I think iski salary ke according.
Aapko fix karna hai 101, aap ye kya rahe ho.
Ma'am ye 101 hi jara hi iska ameesha se.
Mere peechi salary sheets dekhi hai.
Hmm.
Itna hi hai, jaise ye fix hi ho gaya ho.
Agar dekho fix rakhna hai wo bhi kar se toh.
Wo ma'am 14,000 rupay pe laga rakhna ho anon ne.
Jo aapka PFASI karte hai na.
Jo peechi aap CSI karte hai.
Wo 14 ke upar basic pe laga raha ho.
Okay.
390 upar upar, 7 rupay aur upar raha rahe ho.
Hmm.
Toh ye na, dekho up to amount ka koi ye nahi hai.
Ki aap sochho ki 150, 80 aayega ho.
Hmm.
Up to amount matlab ye nahi hota.
Wo percentage ke saapse calculate karega.
Jitna banega, agar 158 se zyada ban raha hoga na.
Toh wo 158 tak rakhega.
Iska matlab ye hota hai.
Take care.
So abhi ma'am, abhi merko ye bata ho ki,
agar mujhe apni salary sheet se match karna hai.
Toh ma'am isko 101 kar sakti ho na.
Dekho, agar aapko karna hai, toh fir aap simple hai.
Hum isko ister aise nahi rakhege.
Hum isko normal wala rakhege.
Add karoge.
Okay.
Isko aapko rakhna hai ESI Employee Contribution.
Isko aap rakhoge fixed.
Hai na.
Kittni value rakhni hai, hu aap rakte na.
Kittna badari ho jo na 101,
agar aapko usi ke according banane hai.
Aap ma'am, ispe laga ho ek baar 101.
101 karna hai ki kaise aayega.
Haan, koi nahi 101 karna hai.
Isko percentage hi aayega, PF ko?
PF mein aayega.
1612.
1000, 500, 12.
12% iska dekh lukte hai.
14, 399.
1726.
Aapka kittne hai?
1612.
Haan, toh fir ye bhi aap usse isaab se karlo.
Ye bhi matlab basically aapko apne according rakna hai.
Delete karoge.
Yaha pe PF hai aapka.
Isko bhi aap fixed kar sakte ho.
Like fir ye fixed rahega.
Matlab ikla hi rahega har salary contract.
Jabbi aap salary process karoge na, upta hi amount rahega hai.
And agar next month ye change ho jaye toh?
Toh fir aap change kar sakte ho.
Mai aapko woi bata dugi, aap salary mein bhi change kar sakte ho.
Kitna rakko ma'am amount bata na?
1612.
Uske alawa employer contribution bhi hai kuch?
Ma'am, ye labor welfare fund hai.
Bhi ho deduction bhi aayega.
Ye toh hata do na, employer contribution.
Haan ji.
Yahaan se delete ho jayega.
Ab ik dosra aap kair rahe ho labor welfare fund.
Ye hai.
Ye ma'am 27 rupees.
27.
Ye aap contract mein laga rahe ho ma'am.
It means jabbi aap salary process karoge,
toh automatically ye deduction mein hi dekhayega.
Mai aapko bhi bata dugi,
agar aapko contract change karna ho, salary process ke baat karna ho,
toh wo bhi aap kar sakte ho.
Ye kiya, then aap calculate karoge,
wo salary dekhadega ki gross salary itni banti hai.
Deduction aapki 1740 bani
and paid salary ki 12,650 bani.
Aur Manu, aap maine ispe se advance cut karna hai.
Okay fine.
Ab advance ka bhi aapka deduction rahe toh.
Advance recovery.
Aapko kitna karna advance?
Ye laga lo 11000.
Toh ye aapko is month ka hi karna hoga na.
Har month mein toh,
toh waise toh zero banega abhi ke liye.
Matab ek toh contract mein toh zero hai.
Har month ki salary ke hi saab se hai.
Ye toh aapka.
Abhi ke liye hi zero karke
we calculate karke assign karege.
Jab aapki salary process ho jaayegi
toh mein waha pe bataa doon ki aap kaise edit kar sakte hai.
Abhi aap mujhe ye batao ki
agar hum yahi par isko salary bana rahe hain.
Abhi contract laga rahe ho,
salary nahi bana rahe ho.
Ye aapko contract laga rahe hain.
Contract ho gaya means
a salary structure hota hai na.
Jaise ki aapko ye salary pattern hai aapka.
6 mine ke liye, 7 mine ke liye,
12 mine ke liye.
Toh wo ek salary pattern assign kar rahe hain.
Har mene ki aapki kam jaga
wo hum banane ke baat patte hain.
Bas maine head selected kar liye.
Incase hoga toh aap amount waha pe enter kar sakte ho.
Jo bhi rahega.
Then aap calculate karoge.
Next, next rahega.
Next karne ke baad aapko dates pe le jayega.
Aapki ma'am isme aapne sign nahi kari thi kya?
Usko joining date?
Joining date, shahid mere
Sukhmeet sir ko bola doon aapka.
Implore ki joining getne lagi ho hai.
But koi baat nahi hum na.
Kap se laga ho maa contract bata hoon.
Kap se laga ho isse.
Agaste laga hoon.
Agaste pehle toh banaoge bhi nahi aap.
Agaste lege kap tak ke liye ye contract
hume future mein assign karna hai.
Wo hoti hain aapki end date contract ki.
Toh kap tak ke liye assign karna hai aapko ye?
26 tak toh gardo ma'am.
March, April kaha tak karo?
Mai tak gardo ma'am.
Ye 31 mahi tak ho gaya.
Means 1 June se
new contract lagaana padega.
Ya isi ko aap extend kar skte hoon.
Aap assign karoge toh ye
contract employee ko assign ho jayega.
Added count 1 means
contract assigned kya is employee ko.
Abhi aapne ye contract lagaaya hai.
Aap iski salary banata hoon.
Toh ek cheez hai,
sabse pehle salary banane se pehle
uske pay birthdays aapko jise
maine bataya tha na.
Ye maine laga diyate ma'am iske.
Laga diyate.
Aap pay birthdays lagaay te
then uske baad aap us computer
attendance rata hai jahaan se aap salary banane hoon.
HRM ke andar computer
attendance.
Jis month ki salary banane hai
aapko month select karna hai.
November ki November.
Aap go karoge simple
toh aap saari employees ke list
aajayegi aapne.
Aap search kar sakto single employee
iski karne hai.
Aapne iski pay birthdays 28 banaye hai?
20.
Toh 28 days ki salary banane hai basically
aapko iski.
Aapne click ki aapne select
kiya. Select karne ke baad aap process
salary karoge toh ye iske aajayega
added.
Means iski salary ban chuki hai.
Ab jo salary bani hai hume wo dekhni hai
toh uske liye aap pass option hai
salary summary month wise.
Right.
Yaha pe aap select karoge 2025
November month ki salary dekhni hai.
Ab hiyaan se kuch bhi select nahi karoge toh
by default sabhi employees ka data aega
jo aapne banaya waoga.
November ki aapne process kari hoge
ye kuch aur bhi employees hai.
Toh aap jaisi ye employee hai.
Is employee ka deduction ye hai
amount ye, is accordingly iske salary ban rahi hai.
Ab aapki paas ye toh
upar se aa rahi hai, overall aari hai
jo system ne banake liye.
Isne aapko jo bhi changes karne ho de
aap pass ye view ka option hai.
Ab view karoge, iska
one minute dena.
Hello.
Haji ma'am kare continue.
Okay, so
view hota hai, ye toh aapki salary create
ho gayi, ab us employee ki
particular employee ki salary mein aapko
jo bhi changes karne hai, aap view kare ge
usko corresponding structure kura
view karte hi aap pass hi uska open ho jayega
structure. Ma'am ye view kaha se
kar rahi the hai. Okay,
I will tell you from the starting.
HRM ke andar yaha se apne salary
process ki.
Process hone ke baad success
aagaya means uske salary create ho gayi.
Isi ka next option hai, salary
summary month wise. Naam se kya
clear hota hai ki aap a particular month
ki salary dekh rahi ho employee ki.
Toh aapko simple
month, month and year select
karke go kar dena, aap us us month
mein jitne bhi employees ki salary bani
ho gayi ho aajayi.
Right.
Ab isme se agar aapko kisi
aapne dekh liya, yaha pe kya raha hai
employee ki IDs, unka name
corresponding department designation
jis month ki aap salary dekh rahi ho
November month, kitne payable days
aapne banaye hai, kuch ke 30, kuch ke
zero, kuch ke 20. Right
unki kya gross salary hai, kya
deduction amount hai, then gross minus
deduction karke jo employee ki paid salary
bachti hai ho.
Ab aapko iske
amount mein kuch bhi changes karne hai
basically kisi bhi, toh aap pass iske
corresponding view rehta hai.
Right.
Ab view karoge, view karne
ke baad, us employee ka
aap matlab pura complete salary ka
platform, aapka structure uska open jayega.
Ab aapki jaise bhi
iska advance deduct karna hoga
aap isme
amount mein bhi changes, for example
aapko basic increase karna hai, kam karna hai, aap
wo bhi kar sakte ho. Right.
Ab aapko iske advance recovery, ye deduction
rahega, jisme, jo deduction ki head
hai, wo yahaan se hoyegi, jo aapko
uske increase karna hai, matlab pay scale increase
karne ke liye head ho, earning heads wo yahaan se
rahegi aapki. Right.
Ab aapko advance dalne hai,
aapkar pata ho, itna dalne hai. 11,000
dalne hai. 11,000
aapne advance dalne hai, aap jaisi 11,000
dalogue, aap dekhogue, yahaan pe
istera se pop up aayega aur ye structure
change karega, wo gross salary deduction
aur paid. Right.
Ye isse sabse baith raha hai, aapke
according ye okay hai, matlab itni gross salary
ban rahe di, 12,740
deduction aur paid uska
691 baith raha hai. Right.
691 year? Right.
Okay, basic bhi okay hai.
So, ab uske baad, aap
paas yaha pe, ab dikho ye to save
hua, yaha pe save hua hai, but
ye tab tak reflect nahi karega bottom me
jab tak aap uske remarks dalke save nahi karege.
Means aap koi bhi
change karo, jab tak aap remarks
dalke save nahi karege, to wo actual
save nahi hoga.
Aapne remarks center karne ki
jo aapne change kiya hai, wo kya kiya hai.
For example, maine advance recovery ka change kiya hai.
To maine istera se remark
usne enter kiya, save karo ki
to aap us pop up aayega ki ye save
ho gaya hai.
Ye save ho gaya hai, ab then aap isko
view karoge, to iski
ye bhi change ho gaye aapka.
Okay ma'am.
Okay ma'am, matlab aap
basically view karke koi bhi change kar
skte hai. Ab agar aapko
kisi aur employee me bhi in case aapko
lagta hai, kisi aur employee me bhi aapko deduction
aur ho sab head karna hai. For example, ye employee
hai, koi bhi hum le lete hai.
Iski salary jo process hui hai, isme aapko
deduction head bhi dalna hai.
To aap yahan se add ghar hoge,
kaunsa deduction head hai, aap direct
select karke, amount karke bhi
save kar sakte ho remarks dalke.
Okay ma'am.
Aur ek cheech ho raha hai, in case
aapko koi aisa head chahiye, jo yahan pe nahi aara.
Aisa ho sakta aapko, earning head me bhi koi
aisa head chahiye, jo matlab koi bhi
koi bhi head ka name, jo bhi
aapko lage hai, koi head aapko chahiye aisa.
To head aap create kahan se kar sakte ho,
yahan pe settings me HRM
setup milega aapko.
Right, kahan pe payroll master hai.
Basically salary ka jitna bhi hota hai, wo
humara payroll master ke andar aata hai.
Aap ispe click karoge, ye earning heads
hai, in case aapko koi earning head
additional chahiye aur basic aapko
lagta koi conveyance allowance dena ya
kuch bhi, koi bhi name ka head chahiye.
Ispe click karoge, kuch to head aapko
upar mile jayege, like HRA Medical
Law and Special Enforcement. To aap direct
yahan se tick kar ke bhi save kar sakte ho, in case
agar upar hai aapko wo head.
Okay ma'am. Okay. Aur in case agar inme se
koi nahi hai, to aap add new
karoge, apni sabse yahan pe name enter
karoge, jo bhi hai head ka.
Save kar doge to wo head create ho jayega.
Okay ma'am.
Karke save zarur karna hota hai.
Same earning head ki liye hai, same
aapka deduction head ki liye,
agar aapko in case koi deduction head
add karna ho. Okay ma'am.
And ma'am, ek cheech aur salary template
me koi change nahi ho payega, in case
agar wo template kisi bhi employee ko assign
hota hai. Okay ma'am.
Agar aapko change karna hoga na, fir wahi ye salary
je se hum process karte hain, aap wahan se change
kar sakte ho. Jo aapne salary bhi dekhne, salary
summary month price mein, aap yahan se
kar sakte ho, nahi to contract bhi
sign kar sakte ho, future ke liye.
Okay ma'am.
Aur baaki aapko contract view karna ho
kisi employee ka, to apas employee ke
andar hi option hai, jaise abhi isi
ka hi dekh lete hai, jo ek employee hai, abhi
humne jis ko sign kiya.
Yahan se aap employee view karoge, to wo salary
template aara tha nahi, wahi se hi aap dekh
sakte ho.
Is tarah se main jo employee hota
hain, humare pas, apas employee ki list
hain jo.
Yahan se aap
search karoge, jis to employee ko karna
hai, aap employee search kiya.
Is abhi employee ko humne assign kiya.
Ab ispe click karoge, yahan
pe apas bottom mein rehta hai salary template.
Anji.
Ispe click karke, jo bhi template
assign hai, usko dekh sakte ho.
Yahan se bhi, yahan se bhi new ad hota,
but wahi se zyada preferable rehta hai, kiki
wahan se aapko calculation amount dekh jaata hai.
Ma'am, agar main koi aap accounts
number darli hain.
Okay, wo bank details basically.
Okay, salary details.
Wo salary details ka section hain.
Jaise kuch logon ke chek bante hain,
toh kaise merko aisa kuch show
hoga ki inke chek bane ge, kuch
aisa ho sakte hain.
Malha, aap ispe se keh rahe ho ki
salary via chek de rahe hain jo.
Abhi jinke bank account number toh
honge, wo toh main add kar doon.
Abhi yahan
payment mention kar sakte ho via chek kar
ke.
Abhi kuch pop up
saarega ki ye via chek bane ge.
Okay, matlab aap uspe pop up
chah rahe ho.
Remarks main daal sakte ho, ma'am,
agar aap chah ho toh fir wo.
Jo remark ki details rahe the hain,
aap usme enter kar sakte ho.
Itna hi part hai, ma'am.
Asi salary process ka saara.
Koi doubt ho kuch.
Waise ye bhi theek hai, aap payment mode me likho,
RTGS, jiski jaari hain.
Aur yahan pe likho chek. Aapko pada rahega.
Ye chek se jayegi, ye RTGS se jayegi.
Okay.
Abhi yahan likh doon ke toh, ma'am, yahan pe
fayda ye ki, ko ek hi bari aapne kar,
matlab save kar diya, Harman Thapu karne ki
zarat nahi hai.
Matlab mereko ye tha ki, agar me salary slip nikal lo
isme do, fir merko ye.
Haan, jo aap yahan enter karoge na, ye
paanch details hai, bank name, branch name,
aapki salary slip pe reflect
toh diye.
Koi doubt, koi query,
ma'am.
Abhi kuch query tab aayegi na.
Okay.
Thank you.